je suis très impressionné
non mais vraiment pas ce qui est
important de manger ma famille est très
menacée alors que le présente six jeunes
viennent 24 ans et je suis riche beau et
intelligent
ouais figuration
en réalité je suis pas trop vilain je
suis à découvert et j'ai tendance à
répéter toutes les applis gk commises
sans doute tout comme andy intelligence
et moi c'était plus de coeur à manger
dont je fais partie de chacune
à toi à toi à toi prends là à toi aussi
deuxième
l'attaqué est bon mais je vous laisse au
jt là dessus et puis comme je suis
partie de notre famille eh ben je vais
présenter je vous raconter mon histoire
comme ça vous aurez appris avec
effarement de la trémie seront donc je
suis ce qu'on appelle un chignon
qu'est-ce que je signe les sens mais qui
a grandi 50% samedi dans le nord de la
france hélas deux parties à la loupe les
parents sont originaires ville en avance
sur mon père et d'événements pour la
mère donc j'ai grandi d'abord d'un homme
fume et lavable vous donner un petit
exemple que le public et principalement
les mines et j'imagine que pas grand pas
grand monde ici a déjà été président de
ok alors pour vous donner une idée
fermez les yeux avez-vous 2009 km
il y avait là les feux rouges
vous êtes repéré un projet qui lui tient
je vais faire un petit saut dehors là
vous sortez dehors il ya personne à part
une voiture qui passe est complet part
ça c'est l'ambiance qui a l'honneur de
la france
enfin mois de juillet en pleine vacances
alors que if hell bourg où il fait 32
bienvenue dans l'ordre la france je les
sentais image et à l'ambiance faire un
géant suit donc vers les 13 ans c'est un
dimanche d'un monsieur clément qui s'est
bien fois mon père me fait bon parler on
va aller rendre visite à mes parents et
on va leur faire une sida demeure 11e
qu'on va déménager à la vigne était en
mode saas et d'ailleurs et donc du coup
je suis parti à la compagnie que j'ai
joué le rc grasse et ses parents ils ont
commencé qu'est ce que je vais faire le
buzz et activement pour la base c'est un
peu débile et donc foule suit on rentre
à la maison la crise puis sur la route
nous permettions encore le faire alors
qu'il fournit à la maison puis à mai
s'est revus et d'un anr en jour
bizarrement alors la blague je passe
c'était sur un coup de tête sur le coup
du sli mais on perd finalement commence
à parler sérieusement les quatre mois
plus tard qu'ils ne trouvent pas
rajouter dans un avion direction marine
on avait quitté les planches de la
maison des bâches sûrement plaire à
l'écouté son travail on avait créé un
ami direction la règle
littéralement vers alors moi je le
voyais déjà rentrant le soir de l'école
accompagnés de petites jeunes à aller
sur la plage avait faire un petit peu à
mes devoirs
chico un grand et vanité alors on est
dans l'abonnement mensuel trouvait dans
l'avion n'arrive donc on commence à voir
il était 4 heures du matin comment ça va
toutes les lumières de saint denis en
montagne ces magnifiques chambres
l'arrêt footix tg j'ai treize emplois
car il arrive lui qui ont atterri
et là mon tour maintenant si vous étiez
une voix avec plein de lumière on est
une étoile qui m'ont fait embarrassant
l'entrée de rêver au quartier el cerro
prend la pose moi je vais déjà avec des
yachts des cocotiers plage pour ceux qui
me suivent sur internet et qui s'appelle
tous que c'est le porte ses 9,3 de la
réunion et puis à souvenirs là bas
c'était une fois en plein loin d'aller
en décembre je vais rendre visite
la suite ok par les voitures derrière le
canadien en train de taper dessus avec
des motos grosse ambiance
mais elles doivent lui aussi aux formes
un peu mieux sur la malbouffe ou mieux
une semaine après avoir aidé à la
réunion il ya mon compte nous fait
écouter aura un invité ce soir vous qui
la mettra lui-même les gens que je
connais c'est l'idéal en bon que tu vas
me l'une des régions va les faire une
petite grillade sur le front de mer du
corps
et bizarrement quand je suis arrivé
dans la baisse sa belle julie manet
j'aimerais quand même si j'ai fait et ça
va bouger parce que quand quelqu'un vous
ne vous connais pas
on découvre les cousines et amis et vous
voyez on voit un outil captivité ils
alimentent saint james
j'ai eu trois mois dans lequel j'ai les
gouvernements quand je suis arrivé je
l'étais façon tout ça comme en métropole
sauf que ça sera différent
en métropole on apporte une seulement qu
on s'assimile non ça ce n'est pas sa
culture ça les différentes maladies chez
soi et on va vite et d'un bateau a pris
à la réunion qui ont été d'ailleurs
l'agriculture agriculture et lyonnaise
le jour invention du compte c'est le
jour de la rentrée quelques mois plus
tard donc cédé nous avons tour du voyage
un peu frustré d'avoir battu par le cas
donc j'arrive dans le collège paul
ammann s enquiert avant ce qui arrive
dans ma classe waouh
un arc en ciel il y avait des arabes des
balles par des chinois légale des
oreilles de cash
je me suis fait mais c'est assez classe
sans doute las il y avait quelques
musulmans et que des planques et là
j'arrive dans une classe où finalement
c'était un vrai arc en ciel d'après m qu
est ce qui m'a le plus frappé la cdpa
tant que orange ii matin c'est le fait
qu'on pouvait vous verrez se charrier
sur nos logis sur nos cultures sans pour
autant le prendre mal son coin de la
bouche on pouvait à peine normalement
ganesh lorsqu'il était qu on les
appelait le chinois asia food ça
dérangeait pas ça a dérangé par mon père
c'était bon enfant et on pouvait se
permettre
moi j'avais le souvenir un an avant en
métropole juste parce qu'une personne
était blanchi la détente des musulmanes
parce que dans leur croyance c'est dans
leur culture et la liste à la guerre de
même cet été sous la figure uniquement
pour ça passe en plus de résoudre
suspense
on a cette chance à la réunion d'avant
développer certaines des routes on a
l'habitude quand on parle de la réunion
contenant chercher la vente moyen du
baril il soit
or en quoi les montagnes la plage
le volcan d'un rouge direct c'est à
l'échelle salariale de chansons et donc
j'ai sur mon plus grand souhait au fond
de la réunion depuis trois siècles en
hôpital et commençait à être tué à mon
sens et onu grands laboratoires du siège
c'est à dire que durant ses 4,5 cm on a
réussi à développer une tolérance une
économie à la ministre à ses futurs et à
ces deux religions sont dépassés tout
dévorer sur les os je vais vous donner
un endroit sur terre où juste deux
cultures comme une religion différente
sont suffisantes pour soi c'est la
guerre vous imaginez ce qu'on a nous
comme richesse et aujourd'hui il était
temps de partager d'agir tout à l'heure
je faisais partie de chacune de nos
familles les mamans vous donner la
réponse
vous avez l'envié on était entre 250
millions les 350 millions
aujourd'hui on est 7 milliards entre
temps il ya eu 2 52 génération en 52
génération y allait passer de personnes
pourquoi faire toutes les personnes
connues aujourd'hui sur le globe
ce qui signifie dans cette salle on
partage tous un ancêtre commun minimum
ça signifie que le toit je fais quand il
sa famille à elle voir je vois toi on
est tous interconnectés on fait tous
partie de la même famille c'est pas beau
et on va même aller un peu plus loin
leur maison c'est ça on va l'être il ya
des gens qui vous regardent sur internet
c'est sûrement avec au départ on ne sera
peut-être jamais on est tous
interconnectés avec eux parce qu'on
partage tout simplement
et quand je vois ce qui peut se passer à
paris quand je vois ce qui peut se
passer à jérusalem mais je lui dis mais
c'est grave on s'en prend aux profanes
aujourd'hui j'aimerais que tous ensemble
on agisse vous savez ce que je suis là
c'était différent sans travail pas un
message vous savez peut-être
certainement nous emmène en rendez pas
compte
ce que j'aimerais c'est quand vous
sortez cette salle vous aviez la
rencontre de votre femme comme moi j'ai
déjà la maman vous vous présentez vous
racontez votre sport vous écoutez
l'histoire de votre famille parce que
c'est en partageant son enfant nous au
kerala d ailleurs sans acceptant ce
qu'on en fait pour en finir avec ces
jeux